so over the last few years my life has
changed my family's life has changed and
so is my bank account so is my friend
Circle so is how much I'm on the road
and how little I'm sleeping so I thought
I would be the hero and I went and
called the local counselor who I trust
and I sat down and one hour turned into
two and one counseling session turned
into the next week and the next week and
here I was finding myself saying things
that I had never said out loud in my
entire life in an effort to tell
everybody how to live a non-anxious life
I had created an incredibly anxious one
myself and so this whole experience for
me went from telling how to have a
non-anxious life to pulling up a seat
next to you and saying let's figure this
thing out together